ich finde es wird langsam zeit für eine
frau als bundestrainerin der
herren-nationalmannschaft neben dem dass
ich persönlich so viel mitgenommen habe
durch den fußball
soziale kompetenz ich bin mich liegen
ich wurde diskriminiert und der fußball
gibt einem so viel mit dass man
letztendlich aus einer großen
leidenschaft daneben auch diesen sport
nachgeht und ich habe mich nie darum
gekümmert ob die männer mehr verdienen
ich habe erst als dfb angestellte
verstanden was alles dahinter steckt und
dass wir aufpassen müssen wenn wir
einfordern dass frauen genauso viel
verdienen sollen wie die männer
weil der die wirtschaftlichen
dimensionen im männerbereich sind
einfach ganz andere
[Musik]